turn your great idea into a reality with
Squarespace Squarespace makes it easier
than ever to launch your passion project
do you want to showcase your work or
sell products of any kind they got you
covered they have beautiful templates
and the ability to customize just about
anything so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself but if
you do get stuck it happens to the best
of us
they have 24/7 award-winning customer
support that is there to help so head to
squarespace.com slash Grace for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
use the offer code grace to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or
domain hello and welcome to another
episode of not too deep I'm your host
grace Helbig we have 2 for the price of
one today very exciting stuff honey
Davenport and Asia are with us today
- amazing drag queens drag artists just
all-around incredible human beings we
find out what they've been up to in
quarantine you'll be very surprised by
the answers we also find out what really
happens when you get the call to be a
contestant on RuPaul's Drag Race and
what it's really like
being on a reality competition show what
happens after how they met
what kind of music they're up to now and
other artistic endeavors that they're
getting into this was such a fun silly
wonderful episode and I hope you enjoy
it with honey Davenport and aja
[Music]
arrey honey Davenport
this is so exciting thank you for
joining us remotely in these weird times
I want to ask you both how are you doing
you both look like you're thriving in
different ways I think I think that I'm
doing as best as possible in these
circumstances like it's definitely
really hard but I am consistently
finding new ways to cope you know good
yeah yeah it's definitely super weird
and I think there's just like these
moments of like kind of like endure mass
hysteria where the mass hysteria is
really just yourself
I've had these moments where I'm just
like oh my god am i dying like am i
anxious like you know I've been around
checking my temperature every five
minutes I'm sort of that person I'm a
hypochondriac on the regular and sort of
a germaphobe so literally this has not
been a fun experience however I'm alive
you're alive but also because you guys
your normal day-to-day everyday working
life is so busy I'm assuming you're so
on the road so now to be quarantined and
stuck in your homes must be such a
strange experience for you I have never
been here and I've never been to it
really I have it I mean I have finally
got furniture a month before this all
happen in on a fluke thank God because I
was like I was like yo I need to not
have a blow a bit I can't invite trade
over so like I need to actually get a
bit in my LA apartment because I've been
between here in LA
and so just on a whim like one day after
doing brunch in LA I was like a little
money I make from brunch I'm gonna akia
I'm getting furniture right now and I
did and I thank God cuz then I got back
here and I was like oh my god I have to
stay in here but I've never been here so
I've been back
making it my home I made a boy in I pat
morita put up my RuPaul trophy next to
my bed so that I can talk to her at
night now you all need to connect
somehow right okay first of all I want
to hear your guys's origin story how did
you two meet each other
do you have and also do you have the
same memory of how you met each other do
you have the same experience do you
wanna go first in second okay I don't
know I don't know why your memory is
gonna be but I remember the first time I
rather saw honey actually at the Ritz
maybe like 10 years ago I was definitely
underage and honey was wearing all red
and she had like these like cones on her
head and she was in this band and she
was singing the song called
indestructible and I remember thinking
like wow like she was calling herself
like this drag serous hybrid and I was
so fascinated because I remember
thinking like wow I kind of want to be
like honey really branded like fusing
together like elements of like drag
music and being a club kid in New York
City at the time and she was really
doing it up thank you
oh it's so sweet so sweet I love you so
much that's me I remember the first time
I met as it was at a talent competition
called [ __ ] mo and posh barn do you
remember this I'm excited and she was
she had like a her I just always had
like a bomb crew like she always had her
like her fans I was like a group of her
and a bunch of other girls who will come
out to chanimal and compete and I was
like looking at her like this is a bad
[ __ ] and like I was I remember when we
were um when I was getting ready to send
the message to asked her to be on draw
the blood with me or to do X I was just
writing our message to ask her to make
music with me because I like her music
at school so you guys you
weren't even like very close before that
happened we got really close like we
hung out that one time they were in the
West Village that it was between your
season and all-stars
we hung out yes that was and we hung out
a lot at at the monster when I worked
there but I don't work there no more
yeah we were very like impacting for a
while because after I got on a drag race
especially like I was doing the most and
then honey was also like honey was when
the most even before drag race this
honey was when in pageants and stuff and
I was just like okay so I think we
really started to connect over kind of
like and that's it he's so inspirational
but we've started to really connect over
like our hardships of navigating through
like constructs and stuff like that
Thanks yeah yeah that is a lot of sense
I was I was saying I remember right when
I was gonna ask her I scroll our way to
the top of our messages from the first
text message I like to do that sometimes
randomly people like it's like the first
DM that I've ever sent them or whatever
or facebook messenger whatever Anna mine
was it was from her to me
and it said like it was like I like your
art so much I would love to do something
with you even a number or something
anywhere sometimes like aw I wrote that
to me 10 years ago and I'm sitting here
gagging on everything she does like when
I got drag race I called her it was like
hey girl she's like I know what you're
calling about you're calling these like
that person asked me to do something
with me executor go that this is so
written so weird
amazing yeah I love that but you guys so
you talked a little bit about how you
guys came together because of your life
experiences and like shared experiences
in a lot of ways and draw the blood
which came out a few months ago mm-hmm
it's a beautiful music video and a
beautiful song but it's very it's very
powerful how did this song come about
for you because it is extremely
impactful and you can tell it means a
lot to both of you
well this song in particular I mean I've
really used my platform and my music
ever since experiencing tons of racism
you
within New York City where I was living
I've been using my music and my platform
to shed a light on it that it's
happening and start the conversation
around it and hope so that would change
and Oz and I have we've chatted about
how different the game is for a person
of color in our industry so many times
that I originally was like let's make a
song about Halloween and she was like
let's make us talk about something that
we actually talked about they were
actually doing or I was like yeah that
sounds much better don't want to see the
Halloween song eventually please but
yeah but we we were talking a bunch and
we were talking about how not only is it
painful experiencing the injustice as we
experienced but watching our brothers
and sisters say absolutely nothing while
it happens and call themselves their
friends is a huge part of that it's like
it will be like if self is like if
someone was calling you their best
friend but watching you get beat up
every day like right it's what was the
feeling like so you create this
beautiful beautiful music video and you
put it out there there must have been a
sense of anxiousness and putting
something like this out there how was
that for you um for me I added the video
as well and you know Sandra misers said
art is just a mirror to life and I just
wanted to show what life felt like for
me it felt like there was blood on all
of these people's hands as well and I
felt angry and I wanted to make a video
that expressed that as opposed to
there's other really dangerous ways to
express those emotions and I think we
caught up in that yeah so for me
releasing it even you know I went to
hang out hours of the day came out and
we were like this is really building
stove use for both of our platforms we
don't understand why and I was like I'm
happy that our story is being told that
somebody is starting the conversation it
wasn't for anything else other than that
that's I I sort of knew in the back of
my mind I was like you know what there's
people who are not gonna want to hear it
but you know what what's important is
the people who are hearing it are
receiving the message and what you know
when we were putting it out all I could
think was like you better receive it you
better take it and share it and just you
know tell your friend tell your
grandmother your cousin because at the
end of the day the real message here is
just community and it's really just
speaking up for people who not that they
don't have voices who think they don't
have a voice right draw the blood while
sort of making it seem like there's like
bystanders is also kind of proving that
the people who are being victimized and
tokenized have a strong a stronger voice
than people think and it's you know
unfortunately it just happens that
sometimes nobody hears this until we
scream and that's why we keep screaming
yeah that's very powerful ok let's let's
talk about drag race a little bit now
yeah you get to iconic beautiful people
on drag race what do you get the call
that you're gonna be on the show what's
the first set of calls that you make
what are the questions that you're
asking other Queens and what are now the
questions that you're getting from other
Queens that's so funny because I called
aza I call aza animal on because those
were two New York City people of color
whose style and taste and performance I
identify with and I was like I would
like to represent myself in a similar
way but like not to plan so like hey go
and what did y'all do but like I'm gonna
take everything you say with a grain of
salt you know yeah it was really funny
too because uh honey had hit me up but
so did Vanessa van G Mateo had hit me up
for that same season
and we were all just talking and I was
like trying not to like give them to
like the same feedback but for me
personally the first time I got on
driver
that degeneres twice right the first
time there was a sense of apprehension
for me because I was so broke and so
poor and I had to do everything on my
own and I also I just got out of this
really weird long relationship and I was
still living with my partner at the time
and drag race was such a golden ticket
for me like not because I wanted to be
like the biggest baddest drag queen in
the world it was a golden ticket for me
to feel safe and happy and although my
first run didn't go exactly how I wanted
or planned I was so grateful to achieve
the sense of like safeness and then but
when I went on the second time girl I
called anybody I said I was like you got
time because I got money and I knew that
the first time I dug up so much death I
spent $20,000 oh my god let's see if
that's okay here's a quick question
because I don't think people really
realize how much work you guys have to
do by ourselves in preparation for this
season the way it's edited it looks like
you guys just magically put these looks
together and that you've had these in
your closet for years and years and
you've like perfectly crafted them but
you're doing so much heavy lifting and
so much pre-planning I can't even begin
to wrap my brain around it I want to say
something that I don't think I've ever
even really come to terms with interview
when I cried at the end of drag race I
was not crying about losing drag race I
was crying but I had spent $20,000 going
home like where was I gonna get 20,000
more dollars from to pay these people
back and trust me it hasn't even going
honestly I feel like people at home
sometimes don't realize and this is why
I feel like viewership can bring sort of
this weird bias with the liking of the
cast members and this is you know how
unfortunately sometimes I classism or
racism can take it into play what
happens is people who come from smaller
incomes or play smaller cities tend to
not be able to afford to get these big
costumes
they bring things that they really made
at home and then you have Queens who
really outsource the hell out of
everything the viewer thinks every
single queen made everything for
themselves from scratch sometimes so the
presentation of what you're seeing
sometimes it's all bought and what
happens is you know people will fall in
love with the one who looks more rich or
looks more you know to them what looks
better is what looks more put together
and sometimes you know they sort of like
they forget about the Queens who really
struggled and put everything and and
it's sad to say that sometimes a queen
will go on drag race and make it far and
didn't have the budget finger but
there's Queens who sacrificed everything
and barely stood a chance and right you
know that's when I tell people that's
because drag race is not really a drag
competition it's a television show and
you know certain things make for great
TV and other things don't and I think
that it's important for the fans to stop
treating drag race has the biggest drag
competition or it's a quote unquote drag
Olympics cuz it's not it's a reality
show where you get to really find out
you know what happens behind the scenes
of drag but in no way is it really a
competition because first of all drag is
so subjective already right you know the
people who are watching or extremely
unqualified well what's the biggest
thing that either surprised you were
shocked you about being part of a
reality program because like you're
saying gosh it's not just a competition
they're catching you behind the scenes
there's cameras behind the mirrors
you're saying things and you know
talking head interviews that make the
cut that you probably don't remember you
even said like what was the most
shocking thing to you the first time you
did it the most shocking thing for me
the first time I did it besides the
temperature of the studio Willman
coldest cold every day like the worst I
was there like my people are from Africa
what are you
[Laughter]
personally the most shocking part of the
experience is how long everything takes
because it on TV it looks so short and
then when you're there it's like hurry
up and wait and by the way shut up it's
like okay and to me that was shocking
because to me it kind of drained the fun
because you realize you showed up to
work right right right
how about you honey was there anything
that after you watch your season back
that surprised you I was so surprised at
how little of me they used because I
know I was hilarious I keep playing no
honestly that's really real like
honestly I'm very thankful for
everything I've gotten from that
platform but like I played through these
memories in my head in like for a while
I was thinking since I must be [ __ ]
crazy like I know that I didn't sit on
there and not say anything
and then like I've been on like I was on
tour with Ravens and Raven was like I
just don't understand I was there and
you were and I was like yeah I don't
understand either I just didn't make the
cut there's some there's probably some
hilarious honey Devonport like
one-liners all sitting on some editors
floor yeah you know give us those unseen
scenes I want that I mean I talked a
whole bunch about penis so that's
probably why I think because it's a TV
show you know they eventually have to
circle back to storylines and then you
know if I think I honestly think they
should do another spin-off where it's
just like unedited where it's literally
just all the nonsense that doesn't match
the story but like people laugh right
uncut yeah I would love that because
there is I mean it's edited so quickly
which you know paces the show well so
people can pay attention the whole time
but there's clearly so much conversation
that no one gets to hear and so much
like even just mundane activities that
you guys are doing that I would love to
see you know what I would love to see I
would love to see that six way lip sync
all played out with me massacring every
girl on that stage that's what I would
like to Jessa
would like to see a live feed cam of me
eating burritos in my hotel room
suffering from like loneliness would
love to see a live live seeing him on my
only fans about or just repent Oh fans
for fans of just my hotel room that
would be an experience because I mean
there's a revenue stream for you I had
to come with my anxiety somehow okay
we're gonna take a quick break when we
get back I have more questions on not
too deep it is time to turn that great
idea that great dream you have into a
reality and you know how you do that you
do it with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project whether you're looking to start
a new business showcase your work
publish content do you want to sell
products or more Squarespace is the tool
for you because they have beautiful
templates created by world-class
designers and the ability to customize
just about anything with a few clicks so
you can easily make a beautiful website
all by yourself and they have powerful
ecommerce functionality that lets you
sell anything online and analytics that
help you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you can get the help you need
if you need it with their 24/7
award-winning customer support they
empower millions of people from
designers to lawyers artists to gamers
even restaurants and gyms to turn great
ideas into something real
head to squarespace.com slash grace for
a free trial and when you are ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace did you know that
there's a company that's mastered the
science of sparkle meat lightbox
lab-grown diamonds they hacked a
billion-year process to grow stunning
lab-grown diamond stones in about two
weeks and they're some of the highest
quality stones that
list they're always near colorless
always vs clarity always a very good cut
and always $800 per carat they come in
three colors to white blush pink and
soft blue after they're grown in the lab
they're transformed into gorgeous
lab-grown diamond jewelry it's Beauty
meets brain go to light box jewelry calm
slash Grace and use code grace for $25
off that's light box jewelry dot-com
slash grace
use code grace for $25 off okay
now I want to talk about have both of
you started endeavoring into the world
of cameo is that what I heard yes
oh my god I just started so okay you see
it all yeah tell me about this cuz I'm
fascinated by Cameo which is basically
for people that don't know it's a
platform where people can request
personalized videos from you so I have
heard about cameo for years and I was at
first a little anti cameo because I was
like I can do this on my own
I could sell videos of me saying happy
birthday and go [ __ ] yourself on my own
and then literally you know obviously
we're busy that never happens and then
ran you know the corn the quarantine was
happening and I said you know what I'm
going to just go for it because I asked
Twitter I asked my fans I said you know
would you guys like to see me do cami
under like yes I made like five cameos
already or six and literally they are
ridiculous like there's one of me doing
the Milly rock with kitchen knives and
not well the guy who requested it his
name was Michael so I was like I was
like okay this are you Michael Myers
CIA people to request stupid stuff to me
people just like say happy birthday to
me or like somebody asks me to like read
the honorees of an award and then the
award winner absolutely I feel like I
just got booked for like $25 but you got
to drag it out somebody was like oh can
you tell my boyfriend I miss him we're
in quarantine and I made this whole like
two-minute video I was like your
boyfriend [ __ ] misses you so much he
said he wants to [ __ ] you so bad he
loves me he told me that's how you want
to marry you when he sees you you know
it's you he's
yeah see now you guys have the power to
really ruin relationships for people
think about how I'm gonna do my cami on
that inspirational like be cheerful you
got this
do you know that the presidents do you
really want someone they were like can
you cheer me up I said if you don't
cheer up I said ariana grande is no
shelter out there strangling with her
ponytail now okay you've both worked in
different aspects of theater honey you
did an off-broadway show is that right
yeah yeah yeah I've been on for me shows
in Broadway national tours I went to
school for musical theater so I was in
hairspray oh yeah wait so how where was
the where is the shift into the world of
drag I was really drunk on the hairspray
for one day and actually was it was Marc
Shaiman
had came to visit the tour we were in
Hartford Connecticut and he had like a
little pizza party and wine for
everybody I had way too much and I was
like mark I like singing your song but I
want to write my own and he was like
look to it and so I quit I like quitters
right and I went back to New York City
off the tour and I was just like dancing
in the club one day and peppermint
peppermint came up to me and was like do
you want to be a backup dancer for me
I'm dancing I'm performing at Lincoln
Center and I was like and so I just
became a backup dancer for peppermint
for four years and like the obvious
transition as a recording artist she was
doing stuff for her and then like slowly
but surely started to play a Mama's
closet was you know to start drag of my
own and with the help of the Davenports
I became amazing and aja you started as
a teenager is that right yes I for me I
have such a different and very odd
relationship to drag with this for me
drag has been a lot about navigating
like sort of like an identity crisis
like a gender identity saying and
so has been about me overcoming a lot of
social anxiety because I always come off
as very loud and like you know out there
but I'm such a like shy person and it's
never been like a persona thinking where
I'm like I put on a face I'm a different
person for me it's always been how can I
really teach myself to open up and allow
people in and and then midway into doing
drag I started started having this
moment where I was like wait am i trans
like do I want to be a woman and my man
and my woman and that I kind of suffered
from that honestly until like maybe two
years ago even after I did drag race
twice where I settled down I think I
told myself I was like I don't think I'm
doing drag because I don't think I'm
really performing gender I think I I
really am flying somewhere on the binary
as fluid and I think sometimes I want to
put on makeup and be a personality and
it has nothing to do with drag it's just
me so I love drag and I love watching
drag but I feel like drag has kind of
just made me evolve into myself
yeah I mean you're artists at the end of
the day rate your performance artist or
visual artists and it's all it's all
beautiful also I'm very curious because
the digital world you know is such a
huge and heavy factor in the the drag
artists industry what's it like is do
you feel pressured to have your online
presence and you're like in-person
presence is there because it's all I
mean it's still pretty new to
incorporate so many you know Queens from
that are like Instagram famous and
things like that like how has that
affected you guys I was never a part of
the like online community before drag
race but I was a New York City
performance artist like that's what you
know what I did and then after drag race
in the platform that I've fallen in love
with being able to share my art online
like that is so dope to me and something
that I never saw as like a possibility
especially because like when you're a
person of color and you're queer it
like our queer community no nor does our
POC community really celebrate us so
it's hard to get like zoos and likes oh
I didn't even think that it was possible
before my platform to create like an
actual following but that has been one
of the greatest things that I've got not
a drag race is that online community hmm
for me I've always been kind of social
media savvy especially since like before
when we had like MySpace and stuff oh
yeah I mean but it's kind of like for a
dark reason because I think growing up I
never really had friends because a lot
of the time I don't know people just
thought I was really weird so social
media was like a way for me to make
friends and like kind of like you know
get to show people who I am and after
being on drag race I I met a lot of
great people who started off his fans
and I think to this day most of the
people my friends circle were all
started off his fans Wow so for me it's
been a way to social media especially in
my artistry just play such a big role
especially since my biggest selling
point honestly is like that I'm a
personality so it's like everything else
is honestly just like piggybacking back
if so do you can I ask who you guys are
obsessed with following on social media
for better or worse if there's people
like I'm obsessed with britney Spears's
instagram oh my god I don't know what's
going on I hope she's well but I am
fascinated by it confidently do you have
any people like that that you're
obsessed with following Amanda Lepore
yeah you wanted to see consistent beauty
flashed in your face I during this
quarantine I have had a guilty guilty
pleasure but following cardi B and my
boyfriend cannot stand it because I get
her off I don't want to see her and but
everything she's done like where she
just goes on live with those crazy
hairstyles she's like
let me tell you something it's so crazy
to me and because but you know what
sometimes she's like really splitting
thoughts and I'm just sometimes she's
live with Bernie Sanders talking about
the government that was so shocking to
me
we're living on world where we're you
know bad [ __ ] [ __ ] popping power
power I'm just ready for queer people to
be able to talk about getting there as
he enlightens I don't like I've been
thinking like in Part II can do it I've
been making some music that's just not
me talking about popping my ass on in
the handstand get am asking like maybe
that's tonight single yeah as long as
it's halloween-themed
you can incorporate all of it yeah what
goes into writing a song like where had
it what's your creative process for that
I for me I need to be in a like place
that like I'm comfortable because that
can't I can't um I can't make myself
write music or make myself write lyrics
or make myself come with ideas but I've
learned that I can like cultivate the
space to do so like you know so my
process is like taking a bubble bath
smoking all by myself
what are you doing clearly I'm writing
and then I kind of just like wait for it
to happen and when it does it's just
like actually is it's magic over my hand
and the pin comes out it almost always
comes out like a fart just like I didn't
expect that it's a perfect way to
describe it yeah so great
yeah yeah what's your process so my
process is very like it's different like
if I'm writing features for people
because I'm more of a rapper than a
singer but I do write songs too and I
just saying but I write raps for people
it's literally like you send me the
in like in an hour I wrote it like I'm
just here you go like do give me the
theme and I'll go but when I'm writing
my own music the only thing that gets me
going is my own personal experiences so
like it's like I got into a you know an
argument with somebody so I wrote a song
or like mine spoke to someone and it
made me think about something but that
mixed with writing the melodies thinking
about like how I wanted to sound I
wanted to go like if there's so much
stuff that goes into writing a song and
you know when you're a person who
represents as like drag or transfer or
whatever people sort of like dumb your
music down and kind of like label you
off is just like some clown and right
you know it gets niched and put into
this little category of like a parody
mm-hmm you know I've never written a
parody track in my life all my music has
been about my life so I think that you
know I think people should really get
into the writing process of my people
like like who are queer and really get
to see things from our perspectives
because not all of our music is about
fashion and and dick and this sometimes
it's really about like stuff that
everyone goes yeah that's I think that's
hugely important to even call out to
because I could see how people can
easily classify and lump it all into
just this kind of frivolous category and
not really listen to it yeah I remember
once I and I were we were bitching at
each other about that same thing and he
takes they texted me
it's so weird if I was wearing a condom
when I made this song they wouldn't call
it condom music but because you're in
drag they're calling this drag music oh
wow like that's very true write that
down that's a great line condom in the
studio it just makes the music's things
[Laughter]
get on the [ __ ] here and the gold for
the studio okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back I have a
bunch of really great Twitter questions
so it'll be ready
[Music]
two deep sports research is your
one-stop shop for a lifetime of
performance health and wellness through
the makers of the highest-rated collagen
peptide product on Amazon and their
flagship product sweet sweat sweating
helps burn calories and sweet sweat
activated by your elevated heart rate
helps increase sweating during exercise
look at this science you can simply
apply the gel which comes in a variety
of pleasing sense to slow to respond
problem areas before your workout for
best results use sweet sweat in
combination with sports researches
best-selling waist trimmers like their
new neon waist trimmer collection and
did you know that collagen is vital to
help support the health of your skin
hair nails and connective tissues well
that's why you should try sports
researches third party certified and
non-gmo verified collagen peptides which
provide the best product at the best
price offered in a variety of flavors
sports research collagen peptides can be
added to coffee soup sauces or more at
home or on the go look at all of these
treasures for you and you have a special
offer coming your way if you go to
sports research comm and use the code
grace at checkout right now you'll get
20% off your order that's 20% off
site-wide
at sports research comm with code grace
at checkout are you stuck at home and
feeling isolated or overwhelmed and
worried about the state of things you
don't have to worry all of us are going
through it and there is something that
might be able to help you out better
help is what I'm talking about offers
online professional counselors who can
help you can talk to a licensed online
therapist and find relief they have
therapists that specialize in issues
such as depression stress anxiety
relationships insomnia family conflicts
and more I've had a lot of friends use
this app and they absolutely love it
the convenience and the actual depth of
help that they're getting is Barna and
you can connect with your counselor in a
safe and private online environment
anything you share is confidential you
simply fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your needs and get matched
the counselor that you'll love in less
than 24 hours easily scheduled secure
video or phone sessions with your
therapists plus exchange unlimited
messages that's the one thing I've heard
from friends that have used this app
that the ability to text and talk with
your therapists at your convenience is
so absolutely wonderful and if for some
reason you're unhappy with the counselor
that you're matched with you can request
a new one at any time for no additional
charge you can get professional help
when you want it wherever you are better
help is truly an affordable option and
you guys will get 10 2 percent off your
first month with the discount code grace
so why not get started today go to
better help dot-com / grace
that's better helped outcome / grace
talk to a therapist online and get some
help ok we're gonna get into some
Twitter questions before we do I'm gonna
ask you the two questions I ask every
single guest that is on the podcast the
first is who alive or dead would you
most want to throw cold spaghetti at I
mean this is an answer that changes
daily so whoever you say right now isn't
who you might choose tomorrow so right
absolutely absolutely
I'm gonna say Jake Gyllenhaal but then I
want to eat it off honestly I I'm too
nice to throw the spaghetti that we're
just saying it can also be like a
celebratory throw it can be something
positive yeah oh my god why I would like
to throw the cold spaghetti at my
boyfriend because he actually got out of
bed and helped me with the groceries
this morning okay
the other question asked every single
guest is to tell us your worst pants
[ __ ] story or close call but you can
only use three words or three small
phrases so mine for example is college
jogging front lawn
so it can be a pendulum
they can be a bathroom emergency
anything that comes to mind wet dream
turn into [ __ ] dream whoa I really have
like two inches I'm deciding which one
is the most inappropriate
well my first hand like what I always
tell tops is bottoms don't poop so like
that's my first and my second one
because I'm not ashamed of my past and
the things that I've done don't do
cocaine oh yes okay that is yeah heat
that advice listeners its own art I
guess okay let's get into these Twitter
questions the first one what has been
the best part about being on drag race
um the the fact that now I'm able to
create all of the kind of art that I
want to like before I didn't have access
to do all of the things and make all of
this music and direct music videos and
have a house that looks like a recording
studio yeah so that is like my life is
so drastically changed from that
experience yes I agree I think the best
thing about drug wrists honestly the
platform and yeah it's just a platform
girl without the platform nothing else
you know it's not that you could never
achieve it it just to take a really long
time so it's definitely good jump a
booty and the second half of that
question is would you go back if they
asked you me Oh a be there yeah I mean I
I don't have any regrets from being on
that show I wish there was more of me on
the time that I was there
I sure would you go back a third time no
I definitely wouldn't I
I just have no desire to like really
compete in things that I don't want to
do like you know act or like be like I
don't know like over overact challenge
or like Jesus or random like parity
challenge so these are just not things i
realistically want to do so i wouldn't
want to be put in that situation because
it wouldn't make sense for me but i
would love if they just came out with a
RuPaul's Runway race where it was just
runway categories but I know that I
would IV I would love to watch that okay
someone asked how would you describe
your New York City sisters um
there's such a big amount a huge amount
of them do you then okay let's say if
you had to what's the major differences
regionally but to a different drag well
New York see drag is the best drag in
the whole entire world
like that's like in the whole entire row
everywhere I've been so far I mean I
live in LA I love LA Queens but like New
York City drag you have to do something
that you don't have to do anywhere else
and that is you have to hold a room for
hours yeah and like sometimes too and
like one drag queen in an outfit that
clearly came from rainbow that has five
rhinestones on it who thinks it she's
the [ __ ] has to like hold a room for two
hours this is not something that
happened anywhere and it built like a
really really strong performer to be
able to like get them you know yeah
that's a very difficult skill yeah yes
Ain go ahead
I was gonna say people in New York will
show up to the show and they expect you
to do certain that you literally you're
in a room or the capacity of 20 people
and they're like Cirque du Soleil you're
great Jesus Christ
okay someone to know who do you most
want to collaborate with you take it
pretty let each other obviously
like out of anybody in the world yeah
it's open-ended so who's on the top of
your list to collaborate with oh girl my
list can go on for my dream
collaboration right now I would love to
do a song with scissor and Lord at the
same time Wow very cool
I would love to Cree to collaborate and
create some POC queer content with uh
Tyler Perry well yeah I think that he
has such a reach in the african-american
community and if we use some of that
reach to reach out to our POC queer
brothers and sisters it could really
make a difference in all of their lives
so cool yeah okay someone's saying we've
seen you do a lot of exciting and
interesting projects which one have you
enjoyed doing the most and why projects
I enjoy doing the most and why I hmm
you know it hasn't come out yet and I'm
not even in a whole whole bunch of it
but last summer I shot I shot a movie
with Michelle visage and Vicky box and
like the whole time it was I was just
eliminated from drag race when we
started shooting Wow so it was like in
in Peter Facinelli zin it and like it
was we just had like I just had like
four days of the onset and it was just
like such a good like Kiki and it was a
great I got eliminated I was like oh my
life is fine like yeah wait what was the
question again you've done so many
interesting projects is there one that
stands out as a favorite oh my god I
definitely just had a brain fart I'm
amazed that all of us are even here
doing this right now it'd be because
every day is exactly the same and I
don't know what it is right me neither
but my my favorite project that I've
done I definitely loved oh my god I love
everything I've done but I think some of
my favorite projects have been being
able to be the face of campaigns for
like big
stream things like hmm pride campaign I
was the first gender nonconforming
person to be labeled as musician also I
was like the face of the Starbucks
s'mores Frappuccino when it came back
out and I know they they they went
through my Twitter because I was
petitioning on my own and I don't know
who saw it but I wasn't bring back the
s'mores yeah
Wow it's the power of social media you
really made that happen
period
okay so many people are asking what's
coming up what's in the works I know
it's a weird time but are things
happening absolutely I have not stopped
one bit like I told you when we first
picked up the call I just turned my
house into whatever kind of studio I can
I've been getting like poster board from
the dollar store and figuring out how
ever I should make art here and I'm
working with a platform called drag for
fans which is from the owner of jester
fans and it's creating a way for drag
queens to monetize from their homes by
creating content just like they would at
a bar and gaming sessions from it so
I've actually been able to survive off
of it and like I didn't think that was
gonna happen but I think because
everybody is important scene but I I had
my services up on the platform for a
year nobody was budging we went to
quarantine and everybody joined and now
I'm rapidly producing producing
producing more art than I was before
this so amazing I'm not stopping I'm I'm
just now able to like cut out the club
and just charge the door fee right into
my bank account period sounds ideal
yeah for me I'm just like still working
on my album and like I i realistically
wanted to get a single or two or three
out before the album like kind of like a
summer moment like a little bit roll out
but you know at this point we have in
the summer you know I don't know as soon
as I hit the studio I'm going and
running and I'm putting this album out
and
I'm really excited because usually my
music I've been very emotional
emotionally angry and I think this is my
first project where I dim down the anger
and I kind of just like letting people
into my vulnerable side oh that's nice
it's a little softer it's a little
softer it's not fun it's still a little
hard but like a lot of it talks about my
love life it talks about my struggles in
the music industry it talks about my
struggles and lives and I think it's
going to definitely be my most relatable
record yet oh okay someone to know
speaking of runways which run away from
any season that you haven't been a part
of would you most want to do the cake
runway no the hair runway from season
three yeah yes she's in pretty much
everything like it really was just to
have Raja
on that runway consistently and Manila
on a runway
my I would love to do it's so tough
they've had so many runways already but
I would love to do the death becomes her
runway when they had to come out as like
themselves like how they would die and I
don't know there's so many things you
can be frost bit and you can be like
mm-hmm the victim of I don't know
anything you just told us that you were
in a very soft like sweet space and now
you want to dress up as dead okay here's
our last question Erin wants to know
which pop icon's bathroom would you most
want to make a brown in and why which
happened which yeah which pop icon's
bathroom would you most want to take a
[ __ ] in basically yeah [ __ ] choice of
are
because yeah first up he eliminated me
and it's so funny take a dump in your
bathroom and then I saw him when I went
to make my return to drag race when I
came back from my season after I was
eliminated I went home I was depressed I
grew a beard in the beard I'm late and
then I was in the airport to go back to
jaggary so I got to go back for that
makeover challenge and guess who was
sitting across the airport for me
[ __ ] Troye Sivan anything great new I
know you from and I was like I would
like to take a [ __ ] in Billy eyelashes
bathroom I would like for her to sing
through the door to me and I would like
to like dream performance art Volta hi
oh but in dark red lights but it depends
on when she was singing I just home I
install speakers into my bathroom studio
apartment I'm going in
one time I took a guy home in Mexico and
left because that's some powerful BM yes
oh yeah I just switched to meatless
zombie you know so it's real
that's a little side note they don't
tell you about you can thank you so much
for being here before we officially wrap
this up usually if we do this in person
we give all of our guests a personalized
fortune cookie from us to you for making
time but we're going to do it digitally
so Melissa I believe has sent you each
your personalized fortune cookie are you
let me go first your presence and push
for people to do right by others makes
you a bright light and dark times
usually these fortunes aren't funny so
we apologize if you're disappointed mine
says the best way to keep cake moist all
day is to eat it all at once immediately
and quickly this is not doctor's orders
but consider it as such for the sake of
your well-being oh my god okay truth be
told if I have ever baked a cake in my
house
I have eaten it as soon as it's gotten
up to up there well now you gonna do
that - I'm gonna go bake a cake now that
I'm stoned and I'm done with the great
time okay we're thank you again so much
for being here and where can everyone
find everything that you're up to if
they don't know the best way to find me
are number one my youtube because I have
awesome awesome YouTube show called the
funk that I'm releasing osdas on episode
that we just released today and so I
have tons of cool crazy things coming up
there as well as uncensored versions all
my drag for fans and as well as nazi for
work content that's drag content on my
drag for fans all kinds of cool crazy
music videos there as well um and I
always like to tell people the best
merch that I have is on iTunes like
buying my song is even more important
than buy my t-shirts so that's fun drama
teachers are cute too okay so honey be
calm
you can find me on instagram at Asha the
queen with kW een and Twitter is raja
queen with queen spelled regularly
because sometimes we do that and
honestly i'm on every music streaming
platform from iTunes and Spotify to
Grove you somehow go to the future and
then come back and then pull out the
vinyl and pop it onto the pop it onto
the pool without it and cameo all of it
thank you again I'm so excited for
everything that you're getting up to in
this quarantine I can't wait to see the
art that you continue to make and we'll
see you guys next time on another
episode of not too deep goodbye too deep
too deep
go deep not too deep back not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Lonnie Eunice post
production sound by Chris Henry and an
extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]